can we talk about the joke you do where
i reminded you of what i think is the
funniest part of that joke and you were
going out on the road for months and not
doing that part yep
i said no what's next no
no we can't next
this just sounded like it became
hard-hitting journalism but really i
just love the joke and also i love a
little credit for reminding you okay
you want me to do it yeah
well why you do stand up in a southern
accent what are you doing
i don't want people thinking that's what
i do
you know let me do an impression of you
i don't do that
i don't do anything like that all right
i'll have more uh more enthusiasm
will you ever see this
wait what bit are you doing the moon oh
okay see the moon out during the day
this is the voice you do when you do
stand up this isn't but go ahead i like
it
i like this
you say the setup and i'll say it like
you i'm gonna now have to record myself
go back and listen to me like i didn't
know i talked like that
i do do a voice he is right but it's not
it's not a guy who just got fired from
the circus
good luck finding other work i'll do you
come on bill no one there come on
or is this a bill from a restaurant
he holds a little paper hand that he
attached to a bill
she says check receipt he's like come on
bill
you're not laughing we're not friends
school bill uh yeah you do
in the southern accent you can do it's
your call oh
what if i felt like i had to be such
like a performer i had to like get into
that space i couldn't just do it okay
yeah i'll do it
you're
we can work it into conversation okay
yeah like talk shows okay yeah yeah i
saw that moon was out earlier today
what
i'm i'm horrible at knowing what i'm
supposed to do
yeah
uh rory i understand you're a big fan of
the daytime moon yeah
yeah
sure i am
this is selling me horribly to anyone
watching
this is the best don't stop dude
the only other way to do that is like
you know that is uh god that is so me
this is a guy who thinks way too much of
himself ah that is so me i
love the moon let me ask
let me reverse it let me ask you a
question have you ever looked up at the
moon in the middle of the day you know
what i mean a day moon in the afternoon
and afternoon you just see the moon up
there
and you're just like hey
the hell are you doing here
get out of here
but you have a coffee too
hey
get out of here
son's on deck pal
son's on deck you know that
diane
diane
anytime i can get diane into something
i'm a big fan of carol
you know i go carol sometimes yeah i go
diane a lot derek always for a young boy
who's giving me a hard time
not me what's your go-to i go christine
for a young boy
now as it's funny because as you're
doing that bit here
i'm waiting for you to do the part that
i
literally have to re-remind you about
you don't see the
you don't see the sun coming out oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you don't see the sun coming out in the
night time do you
show some respect
christine
christine
christine grab your baseball glove
christine
we've got boys little league today
christine
we have young 11 to 12 year old little
league boys game today
i was looking for you to find a way
because you said baseball and then
you're like [ __ ] girls can play baseball
we have a boys game yeah we got the
swinging little wieners little league
association
the little wieners one
christine get your little wiener in the
car the parents that okay that
yes i'll let my kid play in that league
you you forgot another part of the bit
what is the other part
it's an act out you go why don't we just
tell them this isn't even my joke
you go you never see the sun at night
like
what are you guys up to
see
that's what he thinks of me
that was my impression of the sun
yeah but as me as the sun
that's something you're not seeing on
other shows
i'm offended of your impression of me as
the sun as me
you